j'enverrai mais le taf en faisant les
courses à carrefour j'aiderai les
enfants de voir en sortant la quiche
dufour avec eux je serais joyeuse avec
mon mec femme fatale 24 heures dans la
peau d'une femme je comprendrais la
charge mentale
à 16h35 pile j'arrêtais de travail et
luc après côté une femme me battait plus
et je sortirai en jupe quelques instants
dans les transports pour comprendre
l'essence même du hashtag balances ton
port
[Musique]
je me découvre tous les jours féministe
voit pas ce que je me suis jamais dit je
vais militer je suis un féministe coup
c'est en moi certainement mais je pense
pas qu'il y ait un déclic ya eu une
espèce de prise de conscience
progressive depuis très longtemps depuis
même l'enfance j'espère j'ai eu une
éducation féministe parce que mes
parents sont profondément intelligent et
ouvert et que par leur regard j'ai
compris que les hommes n'étaient pas
mieux meilleur ou plus forte et les
femmes
why courent plus vite way deux records
du monde du 100 m masculin le plus
important qu'un peu plus fort que le 100
mètres fut bien c'est à peu près tout en
fait sur le reste et aurait un arrêt à
nous envier donc j'ai grandi à très vite
j'ai compris cette inégalité qui est
complètement incompréhensible
à quel moment en france les femmes le
droit de vote à quel moment et sur le
droit d'avoir un compte en banque la
tous assez c'est hallucinant quand il
regardait les dates du v comment c'est
possible pourquoi qui a décidé un moment
que elle méritait pas d'avoir les mêmes
droits que nous les hommes c'est assez
hallucinant et et puis plus j'ai grandi
et puis je me suis aperçu de sa est une
grâce certainement à cette ouverture
d'esprit que mon mon permis mes parents
sur ces sujets là quoi moi les mêmes
modèles de femmes célèbres c'était aussi
peut-être des chanteuses à tous moi
j'étais dans une avant la barbara c'est
pour moi c'est une figure de de mon
enfance parce qu'on écoutait barbara
chez moi et c'était ça m'impressionnait
tu as lavoine barbara les textes de
barbara j'entendais des interviews des
fois je trouvais qu'elle avait là
vraiment la classe
après oui simone veil j'ai grandi en
entendant évidemment parler de voile à
de son discours mythique serein sur le
droit à l'avortement
je suis donne une famille voilà bien
engagée militante donc c'est sûrement
mes parents les premiers qui m'ont parlé
d'angela davis et puis après
heureusement tu apprends des trucs aussi
à l'histoire en histoire en course de
territoire de ville où ça change
énormément et on est sans pitié donc
autant j'ai fait des vannes certainement
que je pourrais regretter envers des
mecs envers des potes et je suis
certainement j'ai fait des vannes aux
débiles et un peu sexiste quand et ados
collège ou au lycée et c'est
certainement mais les mouvements qui
sont arrivés là les mythes ou les
balances ton port ça nous a tous
interrogés et tant mieux enfin
évidemment j'ai j'ai trouvé ça j'ai vu
ça d'un très bon oeil que la parole se
libère ça c'est génial mais ça ne nous
interroge tous et les femmes et les
hommes les femmes est ce que à un moment
les et se disent mais [ __ ] mais
pourquoi je laissais faire ça pourquoi
je me suis laissé dire cette phrase là
ou et ben les hommes pareils parce que
moi un moment j'ai pas dis un truc qui
pourrait vraiment être super sexy ce
temps faites est superbe les sens ou
est-ce que j'ai pas vu des des scènes où
j'aurais dû intervenir dans attends tu
peux pas faire ça tu vois ça nous
interroge tous parce que on est on a
grandi dans ce truc que c'est normal
quoi
c'est normal que les meufs se prennent
des remarques c'est normal qu'elles
soient moins bien payé c'est normal
qu'ils enfoncent plus qu'elle en fasse
plus à la maison tu vois on a grandi là
dedans c'est profondément dans nos
moeurs et dans nos coutumes
donc du coup certainement qu'on a laissé
passer énormément de choses qu'on
n'aurait pas dû en fait moi je considère
avoir été très bien élevé voilà je
remercie mes parents d'avoir eu les
pareil de manière pas poussive voie de
manière naturelle et mesuré ma une
ouverture d'esprit une tolérance envers
les gens qui sont qui nous ressemble pas
exactement tous amont des valeurs qui
nous paraissent quand même assez évident
de valeurs humanistes
donc oui à mon niveau avec avec ma femme
on essaie d'élever nos enfants dans ces
valeurs là évidemment mais pareil sans
les saouler quoi ils ont rien demandé
sur la ils veulent jouer au foot et joue
à puissance 4
donc on ne va pas leur faire des grandes
théories mais par des petites phrases
par des discussions en répondant à leurs
questions
on essaie aussi de
ouvrir tout ça